doctors warned us to take extra care of
our health this time of year researcher
finds that our risk of having a heart
attack jumps 37 percent today on
Christmas Eve Oh 37 percent and we're
told they're most likely to happen
around 10 p.m. right after dinner so
really scary stuff doctor for
christopher kelly and dr. mark Eisenberg
wrote the book am i dying
should you chill out or freak out a
complete guide to your symptoms and what
to do next
and they are here to tell us what we
need to do to stay healthy during the
holidays good to see you good morning
good morning thanks for having us on all
right so I guess I got everybody's gonna
be wondering why does the holiday season
put healthy people at risk yeah so as
you point out today is the day you have
a 37% higher chance of a heart attack
and there's a lot of factors so there's
a lot of stress today right last-minute
shopping seeing family members that you
probably don't see too often and arguing
with them about whatever families argue
about drinking more alcohol than you
might the rest of the year eating more
unhealthy foods maybe traveling and
forgetting to bring along your medicines
all of that puts a lot of strain on the
heart and significantly increases the
risk of a problem happening and that's
numbers I was gonna say roast that
turkey yeah exactly
stuff that goes into trying to make
people feel comfortable and to make
people feel welcome yes exploring your
cousins political views for example on
December 24th might not be the best idea
you guys break down in your book part 1
head and neck part 2 chest and back
belly lady parts gentleman parts
bathroom parts yes bathroom trouble
rather apiece
what do you think is the the biggest
takeaway when you look at all of the
things people find themselves dealing
with not just around the holidays but in
general when they think something's
wrong I think the problem is we all
Google our symptoms and when you google
your symptoms you go down this whole
rabbit hole and before you know it that
leg pain could be a clot that you're now
afraid is gonna go to your heart and
cause you know a heart attack or a clot
in your lungs but the thing is water
book tries to help people triage what to
do with their new symptom whether you
can just chill out whether you should
make a doctor's appointment or what
whether you should go to the ER you just
mentioned leg pain and one of the things
around this time of year people are
traveling more this is genuinely my fear
yeah
his leg pain more than just leg pain and
when is it something you have to worry
about yes so so leg pain can happen all
the time many of us but the thing that
we worry about as Mark says is a blood
clot because that can have fatal
complications so if you've been
sedentary for a good part of the day on
a train or airplane and then you notice
pain in one leg and that leg looks a
little swollen or red that's a good sign
that there could be a blood clot in
there and that's a medical emergency if
on the other hand you're just feeling a
little cramping and both legs from being
up on your feet all day long cooking a
turkey or whatever your family does
that's more likely to be benign all
right so turkey is cooked and you know
you start destroying your mom's good
cooking everything in sight right and
then you feel a little pain in the chest
when do you realize if that's something
serious or it's probably should have
take it easy and I had that fourth
helping so check that's a great question
if you have chest pain that lasts for a
few seconds and just goes away or it
gets worse when you touch it or just you
know contour your body then it's
probably a muscle spasm if you start
having like heaviness in your chest
especially if it's associated with
palpitations or shortness of breath or
dizziness and it doesn't go away sorry
to be a Grinch and have to like ruin
your Christmas dinner but you probably
should call nine-one-one better safe
than sorry and don't ignore your
symptoms right that's I think a big
contributor to the increase in risk this
time because people don't want to spoil
the party they don't want to go to the
emergency room and so they try to wait
things out but that's a big mistake
because you know heart disease a heart
attack doesn't wait so the only thing
worse than ruining this Christmas is
ruining all Christmases because you got
seriously sick or even died so don't
don't ignore your symptoms and get them
checked out what about that sore throat
we all have like tea here tickle yeah
yeah so especially in the winter there's
dry air so a lot of times you wake up
with a sore throat so you can just drink
some water and see if it goes away but
obviously this is flu season people get
a lot of colds when you travel on a
plane or train all it takes is one
person took off and everyone else is
exposed so thanks yeah a sore throat and
you have a cough
you know you probably should fever yeah
fever chills a lot of laughs but really
good advice in this book and a great way
to frame it for everybody out there
thank you so much thank you so much look
it's called am i dying feel like that
every day but nothing to worry about
it is on sale right now
[Music]
you